hey everybody
John Luke Eric here hey what's up
something of course has to be hot to
drop while we're doing all this other
stuff during GDC and all these other fun
things we're mid-match pub G has made
its way to mobile I don't know why but
it's happened multiple times now where
the iPad just doesn't go fullscreen
however our Zach bomb I think if I'm
saying his last name right is giving us
his iPhone 10 so we're gonna try that
out
I think the iPhone time try that out in
a little bit and you'll probably a full
screen there John Luke's not doing bad
he's got three kills
yeah here guys let me give you full game
retails it so I don't know how this was
for before night but I don't really know
how I can simon
and aim and move at the same time I want
to do three things at the same time I
never really really know I never really
80s in fortnight while moving but you
would move oh you you can't you have no
I do so like you're left thumbstick
right where you're sprinting you can
yeah you would have to say from here or
here yeah so you would use your thumb to
strafe left and right yeah and then you
would 80s which is that the scope right
and then you would tap the screen to
shoot right yeah but like so like moving
and aiming you can't you can't shoot it
I mean I guess I could with multiple
fingers well once you 80s you're not
gonna uh Nate yes right that's true so I
think out if you assuming you do 80s you
80s and then use you use your left thumb
to go left and right and then your right
thumb to shoot let me give you some more
audio thank you but just so you guys
know pub G mobile is available for
for ios and android now it's on the wild
Google Play Store or iTunes - neurosis
saying you got piped that iPad through a
fulsome image Pro I guess so I guess so
Dan but we'll get you guys some iPhone
10 gameplay here in a second and that'll
get full screen hello I like the big
screen here for I'm sure you do but it
the 10 screen is pretty big and you know
I think yeah I think nobody fine yeah
give me that policeman so I definitely
picked one up no wait no you want that
you got that - guys yeah yeah yeah never
mind I thought for whatever reason I
can't tell if I have it on or not it's
weird where's oh it's at the top left I
was gonna say like where's the kill
versus a live feed but we're good so
thank you guys all for tuning in we are
still I'm still trying to plan let's see
if these stream for today could probably
happen later today right after this
after this yeah I don't know yeah I
don't I don't know Ben has it so it
might be Ben and Nick yes Tucker and I
bought it like a normal person yeah I
got a bunch of codes for everyone
there's only a couple though it is 10
cent mobile gaming with Bowser so it is
the legit version I think we're also on
periscope today so thank you for
watching on periscope appreciate it yeah
it's funny when I I saw I searched play
unknown battlegrounds it didn't get a
visit yet there's a pub G mobile and I
didn't get it but even then it wasn't
the first result there's like a lot of
legs but five down there's like clones
and stuff too so you have to be careful
or like other games that are like trying
to be like the knockoff so like make
sure it's pub G mobile and that it's the
10-cent one the official 10-cent is you
might want to scroll down because there
thanks Dan it was not shown up as aren't
truly a 16 by 9 that's true there they
were like 16 by now then I've been 16 by
10 are they I don't know it's fine we're
gonna we'll switch it up in a second
here we figure more real estate for
playing and then there's a pizza cutter
as I would like to call it you got two
good guns though oh I can shot it no
idea from where welcome to mobile well
behind you mind me okay okay so the one
nice thing that I will say fortnight has
as part of like help
you figure out where people are or
sounds or is that there's a like a
radial dial around your your character
and it shows you as this did where
you're getting shot from but it also
show you footsteps oh yeah that's right
maybe he's right - you're right that
tree yeah he's behind that tree or pipe
or whatever the hell that thing is yeah
he's definitely behind that though 100%
okay
hopefully nobody rolls up on you why
aren't you playing on the razor phone
for this that's a good question I don't
have one now heard it I heard gets old
yeah yeah smoke them he turns in they
turn in a green smoke for whatever
reason do you think that was the same
guy I really hope so I think so green
helmet though green helmet I think it's
the same guy just so you know I want I
want to say I don't think you play that
much pub G and things are going real
well yeah well I played a decent amount
but I wouldn't consider myself very good
at it that's very I don't know just okay
I'm in the same boat but the fact that
I'm I've gotten four kills I think kind
of just shows that I don't know everyone
playing this isn't that gray or it's
really easier I don't know Barry Allen
I'm not sure about UK I would assume
it's the same way unless it's not out in
the UK for some reason you just have to
go to the iTunes app like App Store or
the that which is where I got it from or
the Android Google Play Store it's free
right correct
oh yeah pretty sure totally free which
is interesting because the PC game cost
me yeah they asked if I wanted to sign
it with a like guest account or my
Facebook account
which is interesting and I'm assuming
right now at least from what I can tell
there's no cross play and I'm not sure
if there's gonna be cross play down the
road either so either iTunes App Store
or I'll grab that energy drink if you
can you might want to drink that later
to you so when you see the yellow there
will just automatically pick it up so
that's like mo energy drink stuff that's
like do you have do you have to drink
that energy drink yourself though right
like oh you show up on the bandage thing
later you see that next year ammo I want
oh sure cut you might but it's a short
cut you're right it's finding good
that's fine cool all right
we're in the oh you're in the red zone I
think let's go hide actually I can't
nevermind we need to just keep going
we need a sprint and hope for the best
is a fortnight have that where you can
just lock it for sprinting uh I did not
recall the sprint no I believe I had to
like just hold it down okay this is a
bad spot feels good very bad this is El
the drain there okay
what's up Macari Yolo it says dope girl
AKA g or we're trying yeah I don't know
King I don't think there's cross play
right now but someone in chat might be
able to to correct me I literally me and
John Luke we're doing another stream
earlier and right when we got out we saw
Oh pub G is not on mobile now out on
mobile rather and so here we are doing
po ke mobile so I am okay here this is
on an iPad right now we're gonna play on
an iPhone 10 in a second how do I reload
my top two gun
oh yeah oh it's a little interesting so
in fortnight you actually just tap the
gun again to reload interesting um and
here they even have like the prone and
suffering oh there was Crouch draw I
want that you want to win this game what
have you wanted in your have you wanted
chicken dinner yet I've won the chicken
okay I wasn't say what if you want your
first one on mobile that'd be war pig
gaming I think said like better frames
than Xbox somebody had made a similar
comment in our in our slack channel chat
and I'm not I haven't played enough of
both to know for sure but that's kind of
it would be kind of crazy my desk you
said that you're on medium right you got
that choice yeah it gave me three
choices and it defaulted to medium this
is an iPad air 2 so I just stuck the
pollyali asking will it run on an iPhone
6 or Samsung s5 I would think so but
again I haven't tested so I'm not woo oh
he doesn't know no oh
yo it did that thing work okay now he
knows
yup you dead didn't even react oh okay
so I'm starting to think yes pop G
mobile and fortnight Mobile are mainly
created for a certain demographic of
which I think are gonna be children
because any adult would just play just
play it on PC or console unless for some
reason they were like you know in
transition on a trip or something where
they can't do that and they and they for
whatever reason just not even then I
don't know if this is how I would want
it like a fortnight I was like oh this
is such a weird experience I don't want
to play it this way I literally started
playing on my PC like half an hour after
we got off the stream because I just
wanted to feel like play it the way it
should feel right yeah and it was like
okay this is this is better currently we
are an iPad air 2 but we're gonna try an
iPhone 10 shortly maybe after this games
just so I can get full resolution but
yeah thank you guys all for tuning in if
you guys didn't know we're live every
day possibly multiple times this week
just because it's a busy week we got not
anyone's gonna come up from here a lot
of fun stuff web iPhone 7 an eye out for
what try to slide into that just barely
in that yeah it's actually not that shat
here and see you see if I can see what
people are seeing trying to like use the
scope it's like a wait I like scope
things out what I was trying to do for
y'all is I'm gonna try to grab the links
and post them in so you can try getting
them from your mobile apps and hopefully
that way you guys can find them alright
I'm dropping it in YouTube here is which
one is this one this one is the iTunes
app I think oh I probably should double
check that before I linked it right yep
that one's good and then I'm gonna give
you guys the the Google Play Store app -
I'll verify that one yep also $0.10
gaming there there you go
periscope folks I'm gonna drop it in
there for you guys except I can't cuz I
gotta log in via Twitter sure I guess no
that framerate dies it does when you
when you zoom in there is the 8 a is my
name in periscope I'm droppin the links
the hot links right now get you the
Apple one - all right cool
there's there's both of them there's a
there's a link I just sent it in
periscope iOS as well as Play Store yeah
you can also search in the your either
store page for pub G mobile and make
sure it's the 10 cents I think it was a
10 cent gaming or something it's like
official it's by 10 cent mobile
International Limited so G is basically
for intensive games what what's going on
I'm in a good spot right now oh I like
this I like this you're waiting more
than outskirts for other people yeah no
one is moved yet yep you got an energy
drink so maybe slurp 2 of those oh
that's right boost boost up yep
you got what 32 seconds until the circle
closes mm-hmm
so ok 30 seconds now I'm not gonna jinx
it I'm just gonna yeah hope for the best
here well yeah you don't care about oh
no no that's a plane okay well that's a
car
no cool what about Driving Miss King I
didn't see any vehicles this whole time
that's a good question is free imagine
there are though because it's still for
those asking it is free you can download
pub G mobile for free okay I gotta go
alright you do you wish me the best I
wish you the best of luck is there
anything for you to like hide behind
when you get
probably not probably not but we're just
gonna go and we're gonna see what
happens I definitely don't want to be
out on the open if you can avoid it but
if you can't then whatever I believe
absolutely nothing on the circle oh
there's a drop near the circle that's
dangerous that is real hoodoo that at
this point I know somebody some crazy
person I'm also waiting for like who of
the people are gonna do the old
stay in the grass tactic lie and wait
like a snake I'll do that
oh there's only three alive now oh by
the way okay you're in the circle this
is good okay we're doing the prone
strategy yeah we're definitely caught
prone strategy here there's a drop right
in front of you I cannot tell if
anyone's actually at the drop I can't
either
so we're just gonna keep going that's
fair I wish I could do that thing where
I look behind me but I can't I don't
know how all right I'm gonna try to look
out for you 200 them on the hill as well
probably don't want to shoot at that gun
Oh probably not don't let him you know
let him Duke it out and then finish him
although I think he's easy yeah he does
okay look at you waddling oh yeah it's
time to go baby time to go time to give
them the shake-and-bake the circle is in
front of you too by the way
it's getting smaller oh yeah who
wouldn't a standstill battle unfortunate
that's pretty good that's pretty good
for me yeah I'm gonna swap over oh crap
okay let me get his password right I'm a
hacker
look at that SS rank okay I think oh
here okay so let's go full camera here
so we can do a Yankee Swap you're gonna
have fun playing on a smaller oh boy
okay I think we're good
I don't know yet actually I don't know
if we're good I still have nothing hot
no signal oh there you go
all right there I'm gonna go and there
is this is an iPhone 10 okay we're gonna
be playing on this guy the rest of the
way you pick your character maybe I'll
just get rid of us for now they don't
need to see us they need to see this hot
character creator yeah they do all right
so what are you going with here you're
going with a red hair got the squirrel X
haircut as I like to call it all right
let's do it we got an iPhone 10 we got X
power X to the X degree here so thank
you again to our own Zack bomb here for
lending us his phone let's not squad oh
shoot man tonight squad oh we gonna
we're just gonna solo squad it then no
problem Kingdom sure well I put the
links in but I will try to give them to
you again here very screen because of
the aspect ratio it looks like O's it
still kind of a little bit mattock ratio
like oh you know what I'm not getting
your audio you're not I'm hearing it I
know that was no that's the iPad yeah
I'm not getting your mobile audio really
nothing no do you need to turn up his
audio that's series camera while you
figure that out real quick yeah
hmm I'm not getting anything you want to
check his audio settings real quick
sure that's a weird that's one even use
an iPad or iPhone yeah I know I've got
an Android so let me just just message
get some help you know the password I do
but I'm also trying to message him real
quick
fantastic I know it's right there that's
not that that's thank you I'm in the
plane yeah I need to get your audio
though I guess I'll show the gameplay
for now but uh trying to get your audio
here in which case we might have to go
back to camera also it's weird that it
is kind of like theater mode yeah
because for tonight definitely you like
hit the screen two point three five
point one aspect ratio going all right
let's do oh let's do the school oh yeah
that's that's it seems like a good idea
probably flick this side never mind the
rest my squat re jumps
so whatever still going to the school
let's do it I don't want to be on squat
anyway he says you gotta flick this
island switch and pump up the volume
toggle oh there it is we got it
oh my favorite spot we're good
granny Elvis died immediately
ah dude this is this is mobile
you got a happy you got a half ain't no
one knows how to do it all right
definitely some mountain mountain
mountain man Dandan if you played on a
what was it i phone x but didn't know is
iowa's what kind of experience pc would
you call it medium settings pc i don't
know about that come on I haven't played
on a lower tier PC for pub G so I have
no idea I could let me properly land we
good no one know what he came to the
school what is going on I say you know
none of these people played this game
though
that's why I don't know what the fun
just looted up baby now stir them man I
cannot it 30 do it so they'll get a
bouillabaisse on here we got an 8k
already this is great and just Auto puts
all that stuff on for you yeah
give me that we need some armor and all
that junk oh that was you that was me
yes 100% does you because you have 2906
thank you
also there's no lighting after this game
run better on a phone than an Xbox
that's a good question don't know it's
probably because it's like like oh
there's another meaning 14 is good
that's not bad probably because it's
like not like demanding as much you want
that backpack too though yep that's
weird he like automatically picked it up
then picked up the other one she by the
way she how do you download for Android
I put in the Android link and the iTune
link or two to scope hook that up yeah I
think nope that's a hollow but I went on
your mini no oh yeah uh that's why on
the floor now you can put a scope on the
mini it said oh okay yeah it just went
onto your mini okay I played on galaxy s
a plus was so good you swapping okay
well Yankee Swap there yeah alright we
need to get a vest sweet energy drink
awesome
your you have a vest you need a helmet
now alright I do i'll helmet whoa Oh was
he outside I don't know
I'm guessing outside which hat are they
reading I'm Pablo I'm reading youtube as
well as game so what are you shooting at
I'm not I'm trying to figure them out I
accidentally hit the shoot that's
alright because I have big fingers watch
I don't mo hey I didn't even see you
write anything so hello okay this is an
amazing stream one of the best I've seen
all day thank you thank you
part of me feels like there's some
sarcasm in there but I'll take it as a
fully demo full-on just kind words and
if you weren't being sarcastic then I'm
sorry that I even brought that up while
you're gonna single had no problem no
they're downstairs maybe they're
downstairs in front of you I'll do a
sweep still have no helmet though Oh
scar you want a scar others I have full
Medi first aid it's good
where's the link to download this game
again I will put it here in switch chat
- here's the Google one and where is the
other one
it's too much stuff going on let's see
Apple Apple link there you go hey you
guys go energy drink that's good yeah
energy drink don't need a helmet yet why
is it not available in all countries and
when will it be I don't know
unfortunately I literally as mentioned
we hopped out of a stream that we were
doing earlier the mix you should check
it out we played six yeah or the devs
came by with six cool indie games and we
did we played or got to see that game
play earlier so if you want to check
that out or a GC week yep yeah that's a
good point
I'm actually really close I should
actually start heading over mic hula wig
why is this game on mobile they should
focus on fixing the issues they have on
current platforms I agree stead of
making it available on others you want
to know why the easy answer cuz for
tonight's on mobile that's true they're
planning it right but it was a version
of the game right like they had one in
China but that was like a kind of a
different thing yeah that that might not
have been official this one's the
official here I'm gonna put it in the
YouTube description
so that everyone can come there calm
down okay
I'm gonna put it in the description here
is the iOS one and here is the Google
Play Store one I'm gonna update that in
a one hot second while John Woo
continues to play and hopefully gets
some kills I feel like you were better
off in solo though oh definitely I made
a mistake mistakes were made not tasty
ones all right there in the description
they should be I can put cheeky you're
gonna head up to know it's kind of on
the edge so it's probably gonna like how
you're not even with your squad who
cares about the farm you're you're like
James Bond you're just a lone wolf
exactly yeah alright dad both links in
there so go get it alright dead snake
snake or snack this was done way before
for night that's true but which one came
out first it given the race that is
battle royale right now Pope G has has
lost a little bit of footing I'm not
saying that it's the end of the world
and like you know po G should be like
massively afraid however there's
definitely concerns there's definitely
some concern you know and so that's part
of it Vikas Kumar Patel send me are
coming again
there's just I'm trying to read as much
as I can
also yes it is free for those that
didn't know oh there's a car can you get
in the car won't you try it oh hey let's
go I need help did you see all right
there word you're right oh he's got
terrible
thank you okay scare me what nothing
you shot really well and then when you
don't yeah we have no idea where his
squad is we're not afraid though I'm
just his aim is as bad as that guys
we're gonna be fun
yeah that guy should have killed me cuz
I'm a trial I'm looking at this screen
cuz it so G's okay he has bad name too
BAM these people suck yes I promise
bigger but because of that I'm what I'm
trying hit the buttons I'm like oh
there's a guy Southwest
to 10-ish like right on the hill yeah
but I wouldn't shoot them unless you
you're full confident now but you're
also need a reload later not to be a
backseat good if anything I'll just call
out I'll be that I'll be like the sniper
spot guy I'll just call out directions
thank you didn't move from that no he
ran all the way down the hill he did
yeah hundred percent or the mobile
players separate from console and PCs
dirty Larry I think as of right now yes
there is we have not ran into any ones
that has oh yeah okay we do it I believe
in you all right here the left oh boy oh
you gotta actually use that you can't
just use your thumb to - oh this is
gonna be great ready to go he's
somewhere either on that hill or -
you're right behind that rock this I
just feels like a death trap this is a
really good good idea okay well I feel
like you're making ground though oh
we're totally in it this is good this is
good okay because this is running on
highest Sam right now drew
hey there's the farm I've also yes as
mentioned it's in the description now
let's see
Jake Trimble says his bata and slowly
releasing to other countries cool
nailed it that's fine
I really didn't even look at this screen
I don't need your compliments to read
your comments that's not how it goes
might also say it looks a lot nicer on
the screen than it does on yeah I can
when I can people have right what we're
outputting from the phone the phone
looks itself looks better
how are the controls as just host Toledo
TV okay for mobile I mean I don't really
play much like mobile stuff like this I
definitely don't prefer it I always
prefer controller but it seems
serviceable DP d DP P P we're not gonna
squat up with people in chat
unfortunately at this time but if
there's a high demand for it we could
consider another stream for it this is
mainly to check out the gameplay and
show you guys what it looks like and
then also just inform you all that you
know it's out and you can and you can
play you can boost up later some people
are saying no boost or whatever but
whatever there was no way to make her I
mean yeah it's let's see I was saying Oh
apparently Vika scum our Patel
downloaded it in India you know taking
his word for it so check that out if you
can harmonic saying I put the links to
download both either the iOS or the
Android version in the description below
on YouTube Allen pears says this pub G's
or rules of survival this pub G is out
today alright do we want just like chill
here do we want I don't know you do
whatever you want to do man this is this
pub G gameplay is you're like this boy
stur oh man let's see what's up Prince
Rosario this we are in the u.s. Tristan
Richardson currently we're playing on an
iPhone 10 for those curious oh shehide
you right or well um assuming you flip
the ready whoa oh dear right now okay
once you get into the house number seven
spot as we can't see okay
to drink cheese this parts are high
pressure gaming maybe Crouch yeah there
you go
you still have no helmet by the way yeah
yeah I know
Wednesday UK I don't know sorry
is it free yes Beamer boy it's free
Luke's the bomb thanks for letting me
know it's out love you guys love you too
thank you for hanging out
oh yeah give him the business y'all we
go oh yeah uber nice welcome to thank
you yeah yeah use the music won't stop
us from getting kills not today BAM
alright that's one of them Brody will
unfortunately again we're just playing
ourselves he just happened to
accidentally squad pick squads where's
your cell gameplay today it'll take us
too long to get everyone's information
and just two squad up so sorry about
that guys but we do appreciate you guys
tuning in I don't have an answer for the
UK I don't know when it's out so sorry
we're currently in the u.s. I like doing
a we have Monster Hunter Fridays where
we play at the community we came up with
a sweet idea while you were gone
oh yeah you guys are gonna have to
execute that this week oh is it the race
thing yeah the race I did before my
flight so now you guys will race to Kill
Devil Joe and see who kills that would
maybe I can make it better actual like
nicely yeah I knew that up on the fly
for on the fly that was pretty good it
was like how do I get all this in here
right now yeah okay so these guys
there's definitely other people here cuz
that you didn't go good good 46 alive no
problem three kills I got it here I'm
assuming in the circle so you should be
good I'm like right outside of it
Oh Aaron the house Curtis I got plenty
of time
oh is that across the bridge though no I
mean I will have to cross that bridge
you're gonna have to swim or take the
car oh right right yeah I still have it
I if somebody is in the UK look in your
mobile store if it's there do it if it's
not then it's not out yet and I don't
know when it's out you know when you
just have to get rid of somebody that's
about that face my car and head is going
like Boneham right now see you later
right no person lol uber yeah yeah use
do not disturb yeah I will have to do
that in a second Z no James well I think
the problem is is I turned it on but it
turned off I don't know why are you so
crouching we're crouching just prison
probably just left it on and you know
it's mobile cuz like you're very
crouched walking a lot you know I was at
least couching I was crouched walking
because there's I'll still looking for
that other dude pelipper is there still
what you probably doesn't matter as much
in here because people I don't know it
does I think cuz it makes sure it makes
it a smaller target right I guess but
I'm thinking like the reason I use
crouching on PC is because of the sound
it's so important I don't think anyone's
playing this that way
pelipper there's still I still plan to
have my stream to my dudes are still
here
oh sweet that's that's real good and
they all died I'd still be with them
look they're all dead I'm alive I made
the right suit yeah you went to the
school or no one named with the app all
right what do we got ESPN a single to
left oh yeah we're gonna have to put on
like seconds AK or anything yeah I was
totally getting shot at
what's the frame rate feel like it's
okay until certain situations I haven't
noticed as much on this one but on iPad
it was okay and then when I would go
into the scope the frame rate would die
where I want to go here as II know James
mentioned pub G Mobile is the name of
the application this is the ODE this is
like the legit version from like the
make like the punky official 10 cent
version it says it in the like
information of it when you download it
so sweet thanks Eric oh do you play Halo
or hello neighbor
I mean I played halo de la say hello I
have not really played hello neighbor I
have played hello neighbor oh I'm
curious I wonder if desert map exists in
here or if it's just a bet anything is
just the original probably I mean it's
not even on a Xbox Xbox Eric when will
you learn to turn off your notifications
when it's when I learned that it's my
phone
hello Shroud noticed pudgy mobile - nice
princess moon I mean it's just if you're
at home and you already have it on PC I
just don't see why you would play on
mobile unless for some reason the PC
crapped the bed or something I know
something weird would have to have a
shroud pulling right now I don't know if
shouts playing mobile maybe rip sea of
thieves huh yeah it's free
as Martin Waldo Emerson Tasha you got it
he's shaking bags
yep yep no problem nailed it poor skills
we're good
this is great do you think they got the
to the box or do you think we're good I
don't know the box was a little further
out I was trying to get there to kill
somebody
oh sweet you want to see if he has any
like Oh someone got ran over though
that's cool oh he had like no guns yet
no no poverty life yeah but this point
get out of here these days get out of
here you need a helmet though I do I
don't know how I haven't found one this
whole time is there any way to ask other
players in the match why they're playing
on mobile no but there's a little chat
wheel yes okay you can actually type Oh
God
nope sure leave it with that one
I can't wait to die while doing this I'm
gonna laugh if you die doing this
Oh actually I would like that you are
really gonna try to snipe yes why
because that will be really funny okay
we got tested today this is all about
here okay do you have for tonight yeah
we do have for tonight
do I have any invite codes right now no
helmet level two yeah yeah yeah there's
a scar there if you want to switch now
it's good for that what's our reverend
whoa yep as we want allowed oh he's
running yeah that seems something
because I self that good I feel like
you're doing a heck of a job maybe you
should be mobile Pro maybe you should go
mobile Pro I'll become the official
GameSpot Mobile yeah editor this is
great yes the car 98 yep
are we capturing these yeah I am
capturing awesome we're also capturing
those hot notification okay I wanted a
full match and I guess I don't know how
we're gonna get rid of those we'll just
have to cut the notifications I guess
yeah that's fine are you just gonna
chill I like it ah there's a car too if
you need it I suppose that was nothing
like scaring yourself I do that all the
time I like have a really itchy finger
and I'll just accidentally shoot this is
Jake will be like what was that
you guys will make a vid about the 49
mobile Enzo Milo's we actually played
for nine mobile on a livestream last
week and we also have a full match of
gameplay if you want to check that out I
would love to see some of my digital
foundry do you like a breakdown like
comparing this version until I can
beezie version in the mobile yeah and
then see if these is out are you
checking why are you checking this out
wait are you
yeah basically y-yeah wondering why
we're playing this and says we are gonna
check out see if these right after this
stream I just think that currently in
the state of things for tonight on
mobile was at least more interesting in
the short term just because we've seen
so much sea of thieves in terms of all
the beta releases and from what I've
heard a lot of it's similar
so NECA it is live it's free I'll try to
put in I put it in the links earlier on
switch I can try to do that again let's
see if I can get to them nope I'm we
have to move it's gonna have my knee at
the GameSpot name time to go thank those
are yeah those are the two looks and
guess what alright we're feeling pretty
good also we're on periscope yes as
somebody as mentioned Oh snaps tell
stream alright happening thank you
we got along we got another one coming
up goob today's been a hectic day for me
it's gonna be hectic we hang yeah it's
been hectic for everything I just got
back from a flight last night and
there's a car whatever let him go yeah
it's fine
Tengku horizon is not feeling the look
of this gameplay it looks terrible
and boring to play I don't know man
there's a lot of people I love this game
I like to play
I feel like Mobile is there's gonna be
people playing this on mobile you'd be
surprised
all the people that have mobile did you
know I I really kind of in some ways in
my head sold it short when I thought
about fortnight mobile and then I
thought about all the kids that are
gonna play and I'm just like man there's
gonna be a lot of there's gonna be a lot
of that maybe I don't know about this so
much because there's more like blood and
everything but you never know hard to
say can i play with you bro says hit ish
tiwari unfortunately as mentioned we're
just gonna do solos even though he's
gonna happen to be in a squad game it's
gonna be hilarious if he wins this he
got a top three just now and we're
working on a top 11 right now almost in
the top 10 now wow I don't want to jinx
it I didn't change the last time though
so
did cuz I lost I think you should play
with the panels on Twitch makes it
easier to find you everywhere and add
more social ones yeah nikka uh we have
some stuff in the panels definitely
could be adding more we need to we can
we can look into that that's that's fair
I can also possibly the problem is I
can't really tie it to the GameSpot
Twitter because if we tweet about a lot
of stuff so like that workplace that's
something we use I don't know oh there's
a car we definitely gotta go DD after
this closer circles closing by the way
oh yeah I'm fine oh are you you look
like you're right outside the circle
yeah I know okay cool you're gonna need
to boost up here probably tune or save
your boost your top ten now just cool Oh
almost party you're right though and I
don't know how they drove into the
circle or not
so probably did wonder if my other dudes
are watching me or not probably not I
don't think I'd waste my battery on
phone like watching some random teammate
play any idea if there's gonna be
controller support not sure dominique de
coco that's a good question I know that
it's gonna take a little bit for the
fortnight to get that though so we'll
see okay we're in okay I actually got a
domestic slap string on a window on
phone can run pub G and your PC camp
feels weird man yeah a little bit more
people have newer modern phones compared
to you know maybe pcs here we go seven
alive now hopefully you know I'm hoping
for your sake that the the last team is
not a squad but I'm also hoping that if
they are you somehow killed them all
good crazy Oh drop just dropped in front
of you near the circle she's like a
Rambo moment you know yeah
kind of go around here a bit
[Music]
someone said behind you but I didn't see
anyone so whatever
I'm sure if there's something behind us
they would have shot at us or I feel
like they would have already shot at our
five alive oh let's hope it's not one
school oh if it's one squad I believe it
nearly good I believe in you 100%
we're good I'll tell you if anyone else
dies okay again so how do you get a Kyle
Trudeau I have put both links in the
description so check that out Teresa
unfortunately as mentioned earlier just
playing solo for now maybe down the road
huh we can look into playing with people
but just for the sake of showing
gameplay and all that stuff oh they're
probably oh I hear gunfire they're
probably trying to get that crate
holders oh no that's a car Oh what if it
what if the strategies or people lives
it's like Xbox strategies where you just
driving a car and kill people that
actually make a lot of sense what's up
mister someone when's it coming to UK I
don't know Nathan Knight fortunately
that's a person in front behind a car
now
a bait-and-switch tactic for him to run
you over sure feels like it yeah it
really does I think you driving away cuz
yeah yeah okay that's fine whatever
oh he got out of the car or no he didn't
he's still in the car he's to your left
just saying yeah get in this circle I
hope he doesn't run you over
it's gonna be the weakest that would be
the weakest way to end this yeah I don't
know where you went though know where
the other dudes are also they drove away
I don't know you gotta find it somewhere
people are what about for craft looks
exactly like for tonight I've seen it
time to stream snipe lol it says best
girl Monica I guess so look to your left
they'll be careful to your left because
he's oh I heard a gunfire shot heard
another gunfire shot
yeah no idea where they're at though
everything looks so muddied maybe hide
behind the rock oh do you have those hot
lean type um I don't know I mean
whatever don't don't just don't worry
about me
when did that came out game come out and
what's up guys incredible sports came
out today
put both Google Play and iTunes links in
the description below on YouTube check
that out
Calo see us from what I can tell it's
just mobile players right now I don't
think it's doing cross play cuz we would
be getting rekt oh that guy is just
teleporting oh oh yeah oh yeah oh sorry
to the headphone users are you kidding
me John Liu oh there's only one guy live
here we go there's only one guy yeah
there's only one guy
I don't know is that the guy to your
left you're in the circle you're in the
circle he's gotta come to you yeah okay
I feel good it's so good I feel really
good about either way you got the snipe
and that's like that's three nothing
like winning here would top it but
obviously that snipe was the sickest all
right oh yeah I got the prime spot no
it's here right well I believe you sir
for this for this spot yeah suppose to
your right okay
that's right there I wonder if that
house oh is it in that house I don't
know does that be pretty good I do not
know you didn't kill I think so no I
thought he was over there and I don't
know where you want got a minute just so
you know yeah a little bit to these
trees what a shot Pawar's that's right
you can turn on the lean in settings ah
okay got it okay you can thank you
that's cool all right there's two cars
in front and that thing well oh wait was
he at the box no he's up on the hill Oh
are we going for that number two here
come on he's really weak come on
there's bullet drop right but I hit him
I know you know one for sure just chill
just chill he's off the ridge he's
probably heading right now just you
should probably get to the circle 17
seconds come on finalize mm-hmm great
call yep maybe get to the house yeah I'm
gonna get to the house that's good in me
tear left on the hill somewhere he's got
to come to you though he does so you can
just chill behind the house and look for
him oh he's throwing grenades
throwing grenades he's getting desperate
yeah yes you're in a prime spot oh he's
throwing smoke yeah you're right okay
you're going Otto okay oh come on you
run more time Scout here now is not the
time
Oh circles closing I've gotta come to
you I do not see how the company is in
front of you somewhere it was well I
don't know
Oh to your right no hmm wow he was on
the hill right
must have been must have sneaked around
the hill when I wasn't looking fair fair
play damn it we should just hid behind
the house ah all right one more one more
we'll go one more time
regardless we have this knife yeah we're
probably here won't you go yeah into
that I think we I just pulled this on
full camera
dang it dang I think I think the only
way you could have won that the first
time is if you got a head shot maybe but
I don't even then I don't know she was
up right up the hill yeah what's he in
the blue the whole time then cuz that
should have been really hurting so
pretty bad oh did you do you need the
password yeah back to like the like
swipe swipe swipe from down to up or
from the from the middle since your
horizontal try try swiping notifications
now this is like individually turning
them off I want to do that play Pope GRA
hey ice cold flame we're trying to turn
off the notifications so just relax
relax we just had weenie little break we
had a little 6 kill top to
top-2 not only that that was a squad
match and I was messing about the whole
time it's gotta be like a silent ringer
I just don't have turn notifications off
how are you guys streaming from my
iphone we have a oh here we go maybe
this
I think it's show yeah notification
previews will ever be shown okay cool so
we have a I phone dongle that you can
get that has an HDMI out you plug this
into your iOS device and that's how
we're streaming it so in a second here
I'm gonna have the Javan plug this back
to that log back in there and we will
get back into the game in a second takes
it takes a few seconds for it to look at
that I leveled up took a second - there
we go
leveled up all right let's go solo all
right one solo let's do it
round three here so we got a was it was
the first one six six plays six or seven
second place in the last game hopefully
getting the chicken dinner here man you
had it I could sense it man okay choked
at the end it's alright you got that bad
six snipe off the guy in the dune buggy
that was pretty good that's pretty good
yeah unfortunately guys I do not know
when the UK is coming out for all the
people that keep asking don't know
that just Dave with alternative accounts
keep asking you know is it different
Dave do it yeah Eric I need to know I
don't think you would he would probably
like it
boom headshot says go Trek Fabian
unlucky GG IceCube while that was close
yeah we were close man we're close did
you experience any lag on the iPad 2017
or the iPad air 2 there was like a
little bit but not when scope zoom watch
I hope there's a lot of lag like the
framerate would die
all right where am i drop in I can do
school again yeah yeah
screw it everyone's afraid of the school
we're not it was about it I guess well
it's like who picks up a gun first right
oh by the way there's a hundred people
in the cabin ten new then you say they
don't recall seeing that the boys say
they patched it recently
all right
hey John's actually yeah I'm telling
them about our near near experience here
man so close
all right it's get me a little bit of a
I can make it though I doubt a lot of
you will be there it's so far away
it's just far enough away that I bet a
lot of people aren't oh because of where
the pain the planes pass yes it's enough
that you can make it but I just don't
think a lot of the fact that there was
no one there last time I'm like I
definitely and that was like right above
it I'm like why don't you read periscope
chat because there's a lot of chat to
read you just don't have a wheel I can I
can't oh you do have waited no probably
not was likely not cool maybe well you
can add periscope to restream so I don't
see so possibly I'd have to take a look
at that actually it's a possibility
oh wow our own Chris Pereira I gotta put
a chicken dinner in whoa whoa
Chris Pereira hilarious beat me to the
punch wanted to get that we could've
been us could have been us oops that's
not chat let me get the chat up for
periscope that's good just loot the crap
out of it let's do it oh man look at
that
would you get a little three dust all
right doesn't matter just keep picking
up stuff in cases oh hell mmit - yes
this is going well already better than
the last time what if I thought I turned
you off okay hold on let me see what
it's axud to turn off the notifications
he said you can swipe down from the top
right and then tap the moon icon you
want to do that real quick sure going to
Cameron right do it do it
yeah on the top right top right yeah oh
yes set the moon icon yep there you go
BAM that's DND mm-hmm there we go
shotgun move now yeah that's mine now
bandage also where is the year okay
noble guess not
guess we didn't get rid of the
notification all right I'm in the circle
though it runs on Android yes Lucas it
does Oh another best - Wow what if Chris
Pereira killed you that would ruin
hilarious that'd been pretty good yeah
he's like oh look at that just kill some
loser look at this guy standing here not
even seeing me compensators good
backpack is good what do you got a mini
there like that like a scar scar yeah I
would like a scar actually so you
dropped a mini just fine energy drinks
there's a a K - yeah I want to switch
out your shot a yeah get that hot ammo
yep cool let's get some pants
Scott D course scare myself
gamespot get ready there are large
stream snipers that's fine
either I'd love to see them a stream
snipe this game of all the games two
streams night hey guys I'm stream
sniping someone on vultures please I
feel like you're a little bit more
trigger-happy in the last game it's
because I keep accidentally I need to
look more the screen but I just this is
like so bigger much bigger that I can't
help but look at it now I found that for
me when I was playing it was easier to
look at the phone why would anyone want
to play this on mobile as gizmos because
there's a lot of people that own a
mobile phone and guess what the fact
that you can play a game like this pan
usually then therefore creates this like
you know more people have another way to
play the game which is cool obviously
why do i okay I don't know I don't know
why for every particular I think Euler's
pink Euler oh thank you some reason this
match or just keep accidentally shooting
okay
feeling pretty oh you're pretty stocked
up here you have some shoes
that's definitely someone else right
right in front of ya who will win
my money's on John Luke just because
this guy's not even looking at me yep as
mentioned gotta love mobile right now
you want to feel like a like a god
potential god this is uh this is where
you want to be okay that's something I
could use some bear scopes again you
play these games on mobile why can't
make comments which you'd have to talk
to Nintendo and then also the other
publisher developer that's a good point
that I mean theoretically if they can
put on mobile um they were officially
said any five five six now it
automatically picks up the mo you need
Oh got it okay
and they ever they ever said anything
about mobile I'm assuming which yeah I
mean pop geez not even on ps4 so you
know you don't know if they have a deal
with like Xbox or Microsoft right there
alright um where's the circle oh you're
in the circle I'm good someone wanted
you to pick up the five five six oh well
too late it's fine here for a while this
will probably be the last match we play
today I feel like yeah these matches
take a little bit so three matches
hopefully hoping for the chicken dinner
when did we start we started at like
actually 250 210 215 so it's been almost
an hour okay that's pretty yeah there's
a car in front of you too later if you
yeah now we're talking and I feel like
the Lutz like so good I don't know if
that's just because no one's it could
just because no one's know actually
we're not all for whatever reason nobody
goes to the apartments or school I'm
actually surprised I guess maybe there's
just a like a dip you playing as we
mentioned like most people will probably
play on a PC are not hopping off to be
like hey I'm gonna play on mobile you
know so all right so it's a different
audience so they probably don't have the
experience yeah
different like spots also the story they
don't want to come to this spot because
this is like a hot zone normally right
they're playing on mobile and they're
like yeah I don't want to mess with that
meanwhile I got pop in and taking
everything yeah so as for the people
asking if we're playing with other like
people in the community unfortunately
not this time but maybe next time what
do you think it's gonna end up I don't
know I like how you're just out of your
power with no dope here clearly I don't
feel concerned see these the the puppy
mobile is gonna condition you to play
poorly on PC that water will shoot at me
it's fine yeah mutant notification at
least hopefully they don't at least they
don't have all the text yeah I don't
know it is what it is it's fine buddy
the ninja out on iOS and Android at
least in the u.s. both links are in the
description if you want to download it
check it out
ESPN yep sweet I don't know how it we're
just gonna have to cut around this for
the full match gameplay there was a guy
to our left that I missed I was looking
at chat oh yeah victoly is okay you're
just backpedaling he's trying to aim up
dude that was two shots what yeah you
headshot him that's why he has no oh
like no helmet don't even take his loot
despite that okay oh there's a guy in
front of you to lead oh no I'm just
saying oh there's some blood splatter oh
that's pretty good though that's pretty
good I think you got at least two shots
yeah I definitely hurt him are you gonna
chase him yeah Wow bloodthirsty John
Luke's not letting anyone he wants him
to know he's the mobile pro he's going
pro
how do you live with this many
notifications I don't know you just live
with it because we have no choice we've
done we've put in some measures hoping
that you know it would stop it but it
did not you think the guy just ran hella
far oh okay okay okay hopefully he
didn't see you no you definitely saw me
think so I think he go away oh oh oh he
just he just ran over the other guy and
he just hop out of the car to loot he's
hopping out of the cart of loot right
now he's really far away for me to say
no yeah I can't even see him on the
phone he's right in front of you know
yeah I see what he's probably gonna hop
back in the car his car life yep well if
you just gets back in the car and goes
away that's fine I'll be on my way sir
another person there's that guy you
tried to kill the first time oh oh yeah
precision a my like let's go huntin all
right
he's wearing a white coat I mean come on
he's asking to get shot at
it really you think he's had oh there's
that different guy yes different guy he
doesn't have a white jacket on or he
took off the white jacket because like
he was probably like how come this guy
keep seeing me
alright I'm wearing like a white snow
jacket on I don't think that guy would
think that far ahead
I wouldn't okay I like it I like how
your own logic is like would I do that
man
there's no way he would do that right
you're so in the circle I would assume
right oh yeah I'm way in the circle all
right
Heligan this guy's also Oh No
there's a white cinereous he tricked me
meet me once I don't yeah I don't know
man I don't have to tell you other than
mobile look at that you got your helmets
good right yeah I think so I don't know
how to tell it shows a little bit of
damage on your oh yeah it's good it's on
the UI you can't see it cuz you probably
on a phone but yeah that what I thought
no no no you thought this was a joke
Yeah right this was being created before
or fortnight so or that I know it was
announced before at least is there
controller support a Swain I don't think
so not yet at least
yeah but people are saying Nvidia shield
you know that comes with a controller so
I guess technically you you could
probably use those like you know
third-party controllers that
well like map it so from that
perspective it will and it'll probably
be pretty good
alright 56 alive we've killed three or
you've killed three I'm just backseat
gaming at this point I'm like so set on
stuff yeah you are looking for people to
kill now yeah I mean like you could get
a couple more boosts but I think it's
fine if you just have boost you'll
pretty much win that was from crazy
games maybe we had boost last game but
it's basically do you see the person
that's shooting you right I mean like
granted that's the case for PC too but I
mean on mobile it's even kind of harder
to see sometimes so we really almost had
it last game so we'll see I know how
much does it costs acid Stottlemeyer
it's free free so go download it if you
want to in the US there's that trick if
you keep asking the same question you're
gonna get the same answer so I'm gonna
stop fast I'm gonna stop answering it
you wish this was a joke and I think
it's it's alright it's it's an alright
thing to have especially that's free
we're hunting right now this person
doesn't know where we're trailing room
yeah
idea which I shoot at them well coughing
cat I mean it's not like John Luke has
played a lot of mobile games prior so
it's like John Lee can do it
I'm sure you could yes I barely play
mobile games especially like games like
this so I'm doing it pretty ok you just
jinxed it probably yeah and then this
guy's gonna kill me probably alright I
gotta thank Scoob
for doing that I gotta get rid of this
this one mode to actually do you don't
know where that dude one alright in that
house maybe oh that a car though nope
shotgun [ __ ] shotgun well just be
careful now that you did shoot at some
guy that's she us give away a petition
because it's also it's on both sorry
pickle you're still in the circle though
alright oh yeah yeah then whatever 48
left oh hello there right in the thick
of it oh yeah
gotta keep it interesting
apparently Rishabh Chowdhury says it's
also on the place or an agent he's gonna
suck I should've died I know I don't get
it
like Oh another one I know maybe that
guy died faster though because you're
both another person was shooting you I
just heard a shot yeah maybe go up right
in front of you on the hill
go hide somewhere and heal or something
this is getting everyone wants this
package dude yeah that's why I was going
over here I know there's another person
okay I would okay I think you have full
MIDI though somewhere or just use
painkillers I guess that works too
yeah to painkillers another thing and
killer it up alright let's do it
okay Wow easy peasy and there we go back
out there into the thick of it into the
fray I think he's probably getting close
to the box at this point right probably
trying to go for the box
I didn't even check these other days
should I I don't even think you should
let's just see considering there's
there's a guy right here get that four
times scope alright there we go okay
unfortunately Rishabh no duo's is our
last match of the day they restricted
the play area so I don't know if your
how good you are and where you're at
I assume you're still in the circle so
I'm buggy to your left
no you're heading your way there though
else I don't know where that box
let's meet our worries I feel like
you're in a good position again should I
get on that buggy I don't know it's up
to you yeah the packages weren't friend
you by the way at least there is a
package it for you don't know if it's
looted might be man let's see if the
East Room is gonna be pretty late 102
your left yep cool that's why I'm here
on the spot guy big thank you I'm like
the snipers you know the guy with the
binoculars that tells the sniper like
how many degrees and what the wind is
and all that jazz
that's me take the painkiller on the
boost and now get out of there unless
you've made bullets yeah just in case it
just makes me nervous watching someone
like out in the field just losing just
looting yes I'm not by the way I should
actually play play anxiety only because
I'm not the one to joke we had seven
kills 22 alive when you got those three
kills that I just got you kind of
realized like I can just stand on this
no no no no one can and then what
happened we lost right that's true
but I feel like that guy wasn't you know
he also got to the end I feel like once
you get to the end okay we know how to
play pub G or they just ran around a lot
or they just ran around a lot well we
see a chicken dinner I hope so we were
real close to last night we got a
appetizer dinner just tell no shooter
should ever be on a phone well you know
what you got a couple now if not there
was more before this but you know fire
shock on iPad at one point that was the
thing okay
no sorry I should really be looking out
I've been looking at a chat but I feel
like should be helping out
jean-luc an extra set of eyes here we
are in the play area which is good yeah
we're do I want to go let's kind of go
over this way and see what's what
there's a car over there
see nobody as of now there's one yeah go
into the buildings right don't even he's
just gonna hide in the buildings oh
maybe he's not he's not I'm gonna feel
him over well that's two of them they're
crossing paths oh my gosh oh I thought
you're gonna get in the car and running
oh yeah just gonna find them cut them
off just gonna cut them off diagonal
this is the thing I think people just
can't see other people real talk cuz
it's not like a mouse keyboard where
you're like constantly like panning your
view yeah you can't use the altar
whatever to keep like checking in okay
he's still on top of the hill yeah I see
him probably edge of the circle maybe
yes cyborg man Pope gee on a mobile for
real he sees you there's one in front of
you look at strafing he gave you the hot
straight always to you
oh but the shape was not that good
without the guy we were chasing though I
maybe I don't know you got two minutes
audible it's still 25 oh there's a
package in front of you more yep we're
late 165 check it out because there will
be people there anyone want to boost
them later yep right on the field Yolo
just drinking my Red Bull here or pseudo
Red Boy I guess no I know I don't even
know if I wanted to oh you're in the
circle which is good all right
I don't think I want him to switch to
the four times there's no need to know I
was thinking about it but I didn't you
don't think this at the moment
especially since the circle is so small
now like
they got to come to 18 people really
this circle is pretty small for that
yeah I was just thinking probably want
to chill them out skirts a little bit
yeah I should I want you to win this
chicken dinner so I would love to or
maybe at least get double-digit kills
every pretty sweet wonder if anyone's
actually playing it smart and like
hanging out in a building and then just
like waiting until the circle like it
like a normal player yeah anyone flying
like that's where it's your drop is that
red flare at like 195 other way behind
you know where is 30 seconds until this
play area shrinks to where you're at
cool
Luke just doesn't care he's gonna get in
the fray I guess I can wait if you want
it's up to you I just figured we were
close to a chicken dinner there's 12 now
I'm just hoping you get a chicken there
that no that's in the circle huh is the
thing in the circle what yeah it should
be packaged it's not supposed to let out
and now there's only ten now oh yeah
well you can hold the eye down to look
around apparently
which is right next it's like top
rightish oh you can thank you for that
Josh kilink you get to know appreciate
it
well what's up Michael de Silva sorry
I'm trying to be an extra set eyes right
now the size we're closing in here
oh yeah it's out of the circle now let's
spam chicken dinner and check I don't
know seven alive now I don't I don't
either
I'm also weirded out that I haven't seen
anyone in a long-ass time we're in the
circle this one oh yeah
good eye they're like oh you went back a
left he didn't go right for some reason
he's like skirting nope he's coming
right to you oh he's hiding behind the
red box I think this would maybe the
time to do the four times I see him nope
there is should I do the four times
that's up to you he's now moving left
he's below the ridge yeah let's do it
okay he's to your Northwest 3:30 I see
there's two guys there's two guys now
he's shooting at someone else oh yeah
I'm gonna let them there's already guys
people let him all right Merc of Merkel
Merkel oh the white that guy he's pretty
good that guy also plays funky
all right just chill I think he's
running to the outskirts over there on
the open why I'm okay he's getting shot
at he just killed that guy is this guy
gonna be our end here this guy right
here baby
oh he just died no you got killed by
someone all right now the real real
killers are out yeah as you can tell
with the aim from these people and the
bad aim from just kidding no that's 48
all right no no you're good maybe boost
again I could do that okay yeah hide
behind the barricade but that's fine
yeah painkillers - might as well pop
that why not
yep save the one just in case yeah
you're good restricting in ten seconds
it's gonna get a lot hairier oh yeah you
saw the four times they're gonna be good
then I can switch to the two I'm just
saying when you have to fight here in a
second yeah I'm gonna switch to the two
I think they'll watch your back so some
way I don't know I feel like possibly
but Oh was it someone no.8 notation it
wasn't so there wasn't right now the
best bet is if you can see them both
fighting each other and then you kill
the other one
yeah a crate drop next you know it
dropped earlier and we headed this way
to find people I'm gonna turn up audio
for him hmm
we'll have to see what happens to this
next circle oh we're right behind me
right or right there no it's in oh yeah
it's right behind me so they got to come
to me at some point you gotta come to me
we know that there's a drop there we're
just not there's no point going after it
I'm gonna get behind that rock okay
don't even peek a little bit I'm really
worried they're just like behind me that
they're gonna circle all the way they
might be able to I know that's a long
trek and now we play the waiting game
she's not moving
yeah can't tell if it's someone else
until I it's freaking me out damn it
they make it all the way around that's
pretty legit
all right ten seconds why are you moving
he's writing printing out the tree
that's 210 yes
210 Oh coming I was like don't peek man
he's actually good so it's actually it's
pretty easy to get a good solid to come
in yeah so I saw it's coming man
it wasn't the flank it was the guy at
the tree so pretty easy get to the top
10 I'd say yeah once you get into that
10 its people who actually know what
they're doing yeah coach day was getting
nervous I was very nervous there because
I kind of knew that he didn't have a
long scope and the other guys looked
like he had some type of sniping weapon
I could tell anyways thank you guys all
for tuning in to pub G mobile it's out
I put the description in the description
on YouTube the iOS link and the Google
Play link are there yep it's in the US
not sure what other regions it's out in
yet but for sure in the US so check that
out also in I'm gonna try to make it
half an hour so we're gonna get see if
thieves in here yeah so it's stay tuned
for that in a little bit thanks
generally see ya bye
[Music]